[Music]
I'm Chris Ryan and this week we're
talking about hadou key so
disentanglement methods in Aikido so we
should as iq2 students we should put a
real premium on or hodo key methods if
we can clear someone who's holding us
then we don't have to worry about
grappling with them or anything else
remember the goal is always keep someone
a distance because someone's at distance
that means it's harder for them to hurt
us and harder for us to hurt them so in
Aikido ideally we'd like everyone to
come out of this exchange with no one
getting hurt mostly we care about
ourselves however so the idea is I don't
want to get hurt
and hodo key gives us the ability to
reset distance and put us in good
position which is what we really want if
our distance breaks down lasts yesterday
we talked about real cop the Dorian of
shear real caught the door so being
grabbed on both sides we're gonna go
into the Ted Dori today we're going
talking about your top day touring gocta
Dori and the similarities and
differences between those two I'm gonna
get Josh out here we're gonna try to go
to work for you guys all right
so yesterday we talked about real cop
the Dorian of shear real cut the Dori so
that was our dough Dori series we're
gonna start talking about schedule today
and what's going on in Ted Dori so
Taylor is just Josh holding my hand this
is one of the most criticized things the
enemy I could have silvus why would
someone hold your hand well the reason
is I have something in my hand that I'm
gonna use on him and if he doesn't hold
my hand then he's gonna be in a bad way
right and so may some people go like oh
you're gonna punch him so he grabs your
wrist if you if I was gonna punch him he
could do a high cover which would work
out way better for him than it would be
to grab my wrist I mean it's hard to
grab my wrist and if I were gonna punch
Josh in just doing a high cover will
pretty much neutralize that shot and he
doesn't have to grab my hand however if
I have blade in my hand and he high
covered I'm probably going in between
his arm and still stabbing him in the
neck at the very least he's got a good
cut on his arm right so I can't afford
to do that so he's probably gonna defend
with outstretched hands and then
immediately he's gonna grab that hand if
he can but he wants to get a hold of
that hand so he doesn't get a hold of
that hand I'm gonna stab him with it
right so that's why we have
Auri techniques I am using a weapon to
defend myself I've been put in such a
bad position that I need to use a weapon
and this guy somehow to grab a hole to
my hand now people also say that's lower
percentage people aren't gonna grab your
hand out of the air
I hope it's low percentage I hope no one
can ever grab my hand out of the air
when I'm trying to stab them because I
need to use a knife so I hope they don't
get it however if they do get it I want
to have techniques that help me clear
the hand so that's why we have these it
doesn't matter that's low percentage its
percentage enough that I need to worry
about it because if you've ever been in
any kind of grappling situation and
you're using weapon and they've
controlled your weapon you want to find
the best ways to clear it and that's
what I'm looking to do another thing
people like to criticize about these
hadoo ki is no one's gonna hold your
hand for that long a time let's hope
they don't hold my hand that long the
time so let's say I'm coming to jobs
like this and he defends himself and he
grabs my hand and we call this a job
category and then you're gonna technique
like Nico right you got who's gonna hold
on while I go over here apply the Nico
who's gonna hold on well I hope this guy
doesn't hold on because when I go like
this he lets go that's fine
now I cut him with my weapon which was
what my goal was so understand that he's
not holding on so I can do a technique
he's holding on because if you let's go
I'm probably gonna stab him or cut him
of whatever is in my hand or at least
beat him with the stick that I have in
my hand that's why you want to grab my
hand the first place is because I have a
weapon and I'm gonna use the weapon on
him and he's gone from a light
suppressed position to a beginning
control positions that's why Ted Dory
exists and why we use Ted Dory now let's
talk about the basic ways we clear Ted
doors so we'll go to the top paper so
that's on the same side top pays the
same side hand grab now again just like
we saw before in the cockpit or we're
gonna have a lot of the same answers one
of the big answers I'm going to use is
soap double re
this soap Dewar is emphasizing Aikido
all the time now generally in Aikido
when we're demonstrating it we don't
show it with Ando key because we're
saying what if this technique fail then
what would we do next so that's why you
see this as a setup for tons of
techniques but the idea is to get this
technique right so when Josh is grabbing
me here what I'm doing is I'm turning
the thin part of my form towards the
weak part of his grip as I'm doing soap
the more I'm pushing my elbow
or Tim that's making my arm work as a
lever right here to get a fulcrum right
in his hand and I turn and I clear my
hand and that's what I'm looking for now
understand if I had a knife in his hand
when I do that I could quickly come back
and cut with that knife right so for
even knows it I've got to use my weapon
which is what I'm looking for and that's
our basic soak the mooring so Ted Cory
huh dokey are just like all the other
heard okey I can't have a good Pinocchio
without having time your paint go in it
so if I cleared my hand here it's no
good because he's right there he's gonna
get me again or it's gonna hit me while
I'm doing that all kinds of bad stuffs
gonna happen so I'm always looking for
tiny Hank oh now I'm classic when you
also see sorry that Google didn't have
again a classic one you'll also see is
the triangle from this now triangle is
not the strategically most advantageous
way so it's not gonna be the most
effortless way but what it does a lot of
nice stuff if I had a weapon in his hand
or a head switch weapon hands I'm
putting the weapon in his face while I'm
trying to clear this one if he still had
this hand I'm putting it away and
putting him in a bits position which
means if this gets clear immediately
after I could go to work with my weapon
because I'm already in a solid position
for clearing this hand so triangles also
super common for katate dori mode okey
then again we're also gonna have food
Chima Morey and the reason again is
because it comes up in Conrad's a lot I
could be trying to either go so global
worried or try to go triangle and he
pushes his arm up so let's say I tried
to soak the more and pushes that arm out
now it's hard for me to soak the more
because he's pushing this arm out so we
have an inside position here the area of
contention that's not controlled and I
don't like that for me or I could be
trying to triangle and it didn't work so
I try triangle and notice again we have
this open position here there's no good
for me now what will come off that
really nicely is Buchi mawari now
understand her coochie more I heard oh
please don't come off of turning in
front of him this is not a good et
memorial the reason is he's right there
he's gonna get me a Gucci Mori shoots
through like this if I'm pushing through
to get here it's exactly like a duck
under in wrestling except he's got a
hold on my wrist so we're here in this
position I'm shooting underneath like
this so I'm trying to get out and I'm
shooting back here now he's still gonna
hold to me we get sunk oh right there
waiting for me we also have a cross eqo
like this tons of techniques will appear
for me from there but that's the basic
idea so again we can take those ideas we
had for cos the Dory and we can apply
them generally to Catoctin right now guy
Aquitaine or cross hand-grabber
believe it or not we're gonna have a lot
of the same situations from here however
most of the time from this we're gonna
be dealing with him desiring to get the
eating me position on me so look he's
getting et me on me no good so as this
guy's coming to get me I'm gonna be
positioning out like this
go front on so they can see so if josh
is coming to my back I'm gonna be
turning this way now if it comes to my
back again I'll turn this way you'll see
every time we're going to a 45 position
into an eye honey now from that what can
I get
well if I rolled this way I can get an
eto generally to clear my hand if you
push my hand the other way I can get a
quarter done so you can see the
corrugation they're getting the Kota
gangsta pop free yes I'm quit and
managed to get all the way to the
outside I'll get my otach so meaning if
he's coming to my back foot I'm faster
than him I'll get to this position I can
pop three what if this guy's faster than
me understand we always have to account
for that night kiddo
so if he's coming to my back he's faster
than me I shoot through and we get lucci
mawari back to this position so those
are the basic concepts we're gonna use
intense someone grabs our hand
the goal is not to get this guy so my
goal is not to try and hurt Josh and
that's not for a moral reason I'm not
like in my head going like all I want to
be a good boy and so I won't hurt my
attacker that's not like my mindset my
mind says he's a big ferocious beast and
if I get in a fight with him he's gonna
beat me up
and I don't want this guy to beat me up
so I'm just trying to get free so he
won't murder me so every time he's
grabbing hold of me I'm trying to clear
and get out of there clear and get out
of it
I Aikido is truly a self-defense system
the objective is not to assault this guy
it's to not allow him to assault me as
the goal tomorrow we're gonna talk about
sushiro Rio thaen a bunch of interesting
stuff that comes up with your sheer real
thing I'm Chris Frey this is Aikido
Fresno thanks for watching
[Music]